.
I think it's commonplace
The idea of ​​square root, but I would like to clarify some
The terms at least, I always find
At first vague, I want to make it
Very clear in your mind
If you type 9 inside the root code of the square, I think you know
Read it as the square root of 9
But I want to explain
When you see the number inside the root code like this
This means the basic square root of 9
When I say the basic square root, I really say
The positive square root of 9
If this phrase equals 3
I will be clear here because you probably know
9 has two square roots
By definition, the square root is a spring root
For 9 is a number, if you squared, the output will be 9
3 is a square root, plus -3
3. Also a square root
But if you just type the root code, you do
Means the positive square root, or
Basic square root
If you want things to return to the negative square root
You place a negative signal in front of the root symbol
This equals -3
Or if you want to take both the positive and
Negative, both the root root and the negative square root
You will write a positive or negative signal in front of
Root code
Of course, this is equal to positive or negative 3
So now what I want to talk about is
Representation of conjugation, y =
Square root of x
See how it is associated with the conjunction y = x - call me
Write this here because I will do it
See how y = x ^ 2 is associated
Hence, if you have some time, we will focus on them
A little bit we get a better understanding of what makes
These associations move up and down or to the left and right
So let's do the value of the table before getting
Account Representation
If we have y = x ^ 2
We have x and y values
This is y = the square root of x
Again, we have x and y values ​​here
So let me choose random values ​​for x here
I will remain in the positive field of x
Suppose that x = 0, 1 - Let me
I color it
When x = 0, how much is y?
Well y = x ^ 2
0 ^ 2 = 0
When x = 1, y would be 1 ^ 2, i
When x = 2, y would be 2 ^ 2, ie 4
When x = 3, y would be 3 ^ 2, ie 9
We have seen this before
I can continue
Let me add 4 here
When x = 4, y would be 4 ^ 2, ie 16
We have seen all this
We have represented the equivalent plots
This was all a review
Now let's see what happens when y =
Square root of x
Let's see what happens
I will choose some X values ​​to make them
it's interesting
When x = 0, how much would y?
How much is the square root of 0?
Well it's 0
0 ^ 2 = 0
When x = 1, the square root of x is any
L 1 equals positive 1
It has another square root which is -1, but
We have no positive or negative references written here
We have only a square root
When x = 4, how much y?
Well, the square root of 4 is positive 2
When x = 9, how much y?
When x = 9, the square root
For 9 equals 3
Finally, when x = 16, square root
For 16 is 4
If you think you have already seen how they are related to each other
We only switched x and y
Well, they are the same x and y, but we have here
x = 2, y = 4
Here x = 4, y = 2
3.9, 9.3
4.16, 16.4
This is logical
If you cross both ends of the equation
You will get y ^ 2 = x
Of course, the range of y values ​​will be limited to
Values ​​y are positive because only meal values ​​can be taken
Because this is a basic square root
But the general idea is that we have switched x and y
Between this pairing and this pairing, if
Suppose that the field x and y are positive
Now, let's see how the graphic representation will look
I guess you probably have guessed - call me
I represent them here
Let me do them manually because I think this is my tutorial
At times before extracting the graph calculator
If I stay in the positive quarter, ie in the first
A quarter here
Let me do this first
If we have point 0,0, point 1.1, and point 2
, 2, which I have to draw
Just a little smaller than these
Let me define this 1, 2, 3
Let me do this
I'll go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11
12, 13, 14, 15, 16
This is the distance I have to move
Then I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13
14, 15, 16
This is the distance I will move in this direction
Now let us represent it
If we have 0, 0, 1, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4
2.4 Here
3.9
3, 5,6,7,8,9
3,9 are located here
And then we have 4,16
4.16 will be here
If y = x ^ 2, and
We've seen this before
It will look like this
We represented it in the positive quarter, so we got it
The shape of the u that looks like this
So
Now let's represent y =
Square root of x
If here, again, we have 0,0
We have 1,1
We have 4.2
1, 2, 3, 4, 2
We have 9,3
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 3 here
Then we have 16.4
16.4 are located here
So the representation will look like this
Notice, they seem like
Turning around the axes
This is open along the y axis, and this is open along
X axis
Again, this is quite logical because we did
By switching x and y
Especially if the first quarter is taken into consideration
Indeed, they are symmetric around the line, y
= x
We will talk about these things in the future
Parity around the line, y = x
We can better represent it
Graph Calculator
I found this on the website
You did a quick search on the website
I want to give a good credit to people who
Use their source
This is my.hrw.com/math06 website
You can turn this off
I hope you can read this
Especially if viewed by HD
But let us represent all these things
Let us represent them more clearly than
What I can do manually
In fact, let me bring what you have written here
If this
He must give you - well
Let's first represent y = x ^ 2
And then in green, let me paint y =
Square root of x
There are many buttons here on the right, you know
what I do
I have several buttons here: square code and
Root icon and all this
Let me focus on this
If they let me represent them
I first represented x ^ 2 and then painted
The spring root of x
See, if you concentrate on the first quarter here
You'll see that you got the same output that you got
There, although what I got was more messy
Now, for fun and, as you know, I did not do this
After using familiar quarters
Let's see what happens
What we need to do is to move the different representations
If with x ^ 2, I will do two things
I will scale the drawings and move them
If this is x ^ 2
Let's focus only on x ^ 2 and see what happens
When we are graduating
Then I'll do it with the root code too
This will work for anything
Let's see what happens when we get 2 x - no, not 2 ^ 2
- 2 x x ^ 2
Let's do one other solution, which is 1.5 × 0 - I can
Make a 0.4 solution already
0.5 × x ^ 2
Let us represent them
If x ^ 2
Note that x ^ 2 is not red
If we scale it by 2, the shape will remain parabola
Head in the same place, but we move up both
Two directions
If we have 0.5 × x ^ 2, we will still have
Parabola, but we move up a little slower
We have u wide open but staging factor
Less than 1
If so, decide how much expansion or contraction
Parabola slot
And then if you want to move it to the left or to the right
I want you to think about why this is
If this is x ^ 2
Let me assume that I want you to take the representation of x ^ 2 and
I want to move it by 4 units to the right
What I do is say x - 4
x-4) ^ 2)
If you want to move it by 2 to - let us assume that I am
I'll move it 2 to the left. x 2) ^ 2)
What will we get?
They noticed it as I said. x - 4) ^ 2) may
Move 4 units to the right
x 2) ^ 2), moved two units to the left
Guy may seem intuitive at first, this is the stirring that you are
I'm talking about him
But think about what is happening
Here, the head falls on point x = 0
When you get here at 0 ^ 2
Now here, the head falls on x = 4
But when x = 4, you will put 4 here
And you get 4, -4
If it stays zero
4, -4 = 0 and this is what you are squaring
Here, when x = -2 - minus 2 + 2
- You are squaring zero
So in other words, whatever the value you are squaring, the 0 will be
Equal to 4 here
And 4 = 0
And -2 = 0 there
If I want you to think about this a bit
Another way you can think about this is when x =
1, we are on the point of red parabola
But when x = 5 on the green pieces
We will have a 5 - 4
Inside our brackets 1, such as x =
1 here, at the top
If we are on the same point in the parabola
I want you to think about this a bit
Perhaps it is not self-evident to say
4. Move it to the right and press 2 to
the left
But this is already logical
Now, the other interesting thing is moving
Stuff up and down
This is actually direct
You want to move this curve up
Let's assume we want to move the red curve slightly up
We represent x ^ 2 + 1
Note that it has been moved up
If you want this green curve to move down by 5 units, place it
5. Here
Then represent it and move 5 units down
If you want to be open a little wider than this, then maybe you should
Step down slightly
Run it down and assume 0.5 × this
If now the green curve will be listed down and will open
Slightly wider
The same idea can be applied to
Sqrt
Let me do this
Let me apply the same idea
The same idea can be applied to any coupling
Let's then represent the square root of x
Using the green color, let's represent the square root of x
Let me say -5
If we move it to the top on the right by 5 units
And then assume that we have a square root of x + 4
Move it to the left by 4 units
Let's move it down by 3 units
Let us represent all this
Square root of x
Then we have a square root of x-5
Note that it is the same square root of x
But I moved it to the right by 5 units
When x = 5, I have 0 inside the root code
Same square root of 0
If this point is equal to that
Now when I have the square root of x + 4, move it
To the left by 4 units
When x = -4, I have 0 inside the root code
If this point is equal to that
Then you subtract 3, also you move it down by 3 units
This is the starting point
If you want to open this square blue root for a little bit
It will be a little tight
I will list it down
If here, when you put a few staging down and makes
It is more narrow because it is open to the length of the x axis
So let me do this
Let me begin with this in green - let me expand it
Let me assume that it is 3 × square root for x - 5
So let's draw all this
They noted, this decree in blue is now open to the top and more narrow
The green sign is open up a bit now, I guess you are
She says, a little faster
It has been taught
Then you can move this up slightly by 4 units
Then we represent him so
Note that when we represent this, it is not a deviation
The parabola we talked about
Basic square root
If you represent a positive or negative square root, in fact
It will not be a logical association because it is
You will have two values ​​for y for each x value
Therefore, use the base square root
Anyway, I hope you have found this explanation
On the relations between the equivalence segments, and / or between x ^ 2
Basic square roots, useful
And how to move them
This will be very useful in the future
When we talk about inverse and moving conjugates
.